[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
erstes WM Halbfinale und Kristin der DFB
plant sowas wie ein Neustart mit
prominenten Beratern guten Abend wir
schauen auf die heutigen Themen
die EU macht Ernst Brüssel blockiert
Milliardenzahlungen an Ungarn wegen
unzureichender Korruptionsbekämpfung
Entlastungen auch für Besitzer von Öl
und Pelletheizungen die Ampel plant bis
zu 2000 Euro Zuschuss pro Haushalt
Meilenstein für künftige
Energiegewinnung forschende aus den USA
haben einen neuen Weg bei der Kernfusion
gefunden
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit wichtigen Gesetzen aus
Brüssel und einem deutlichen Signal
Richtung Ungarn lange wurde gedroht
jetzt passiert ist tatsächlich die EU
friert Milliarden Mittel für Budapest
ein wegen anhaltender rechtsstaatsmängel
historisch nennen das viele und damit
Ungarn nicht noch mehr Geld entgeht
stimmte das Land nach langer Blockade
jetzt doch für massive Ukraine Hilfen
und eine globale Mindeststeuer Florian
neuhahn berichtet
es ist spät gestern Abend da verkündet
die tschechische EU-Ratspräsidentschaft
überraschend einen mega Deal eine
Einigung im langen Streit zwischen
Ungarn und dem Rest der EU die viele am
Morgen danach bejubeln
wir haben einen breiten Konsens dafür
gefunden und das zeigt eben auch dass
diese Werte wie Rechtsstaatlichkeit
nicht verhandelbar sind zuletzt hatte
der ungarische Ministerpräsident Viktor
Orban wichtige EU-Entscheidungen
blockiert wohl um Strafen für Korruption
und Mängel beim Rechtsstaat abzuwenden
doch der Rest ließ sich nicht erpressen
und so werden nun erstmals Gelder für
einen EU-Mitgliedsstaat blockiert in
Höhe von 6,3 Milliarden Euro weitere 5,8
Milliarden aus dem Corona Aufbau vor
werden erst gezahlt wenn Ungarn seinen
Rechtsstaat reformiert auf der anderen
Seite stimmt Ungarn nun dem zu was es
bisher blockierte eine EU-weite
Mindeststeuer von 15% für Unternehmen
und 18 Milliarden Euro Finanzhilfe für
die Ukraine
zum ersten Mal haben die
Mitgliedsstaaten tatsächlich gesagt hier
ist Stopp deswegen ist diese
Entscheidung auch ein Signal über Ungarn
hinaus wer die EU Werte nicht achtet der
muss mit finanziellen Sanktionen rechnen
das ist eine Niederlage für Viktor Orban
dieser eine Justizministerin heute
kreativ umzudeuten versucht
das sind keine Sanktionen es gibt eine
Einigung es gibt einen klaren Weg einen
Prozess aber keine Sanktionen
es ist eine Interpretation mit der
Ungarn heute allein da steht wenig
später wären die Corona Milliarden für
Ungarn komplett verfallen während dem
Land zu Hause finanziell das Wasser
längst bis zum Hals steht wohl auch
deshalb heißt es in Brüssel blieb
arbeiten jetzt keine andere Wahl als
einzulenken
wir gehen zu Einordnung noch mal nach
Brüssel zu Ulf Röller Ulf die EU friert
Milliarden für Ungarn ein welches Signal
geht von dieser beispiellosen
Entscheidung aus
ich glaube schon dass man sagen kann das
hat ein historische Dimension Viktor
Orban hat ja ganz brutal sehr einfach
gesagt versucht die Europäische Union zu
erpressen er hat sehr klar gesagt dass
er kein keine Ukraine Hilfe mehr oder
weniger zustimmen wird solange nicht
Geld für ihn fließt er hat versucht mit
dieser Erpressung eben zu erreichen dass
die Europäische Union nicht so genau
hinguckt bei seinen Brüchen des
Rechtsstaats und bei seiner Korruption
aber die Europäische Union hat sich
darauf nicht eingelassen auch vor allem
Deutschland hat sehr stark darauf
gedrängt dass man eben nicht umfällt und
hat sehr deutlich urban gemacht wenn er
nicht einlenkt dann werden langfristig
die Gelder die er dringend braucht nicht
kommen und dann ist jetzt umgefallen
insofern das ist historische Dimension
war das heute ein sehr guter Tag für den
Rechtsstaat in Europa danke für die
Einordnung nach Brüsseler ja und wie
eingangs erwähnt die EU-Staaten wollen
jetzt gemeinsam auch eine globale
Mindeststeuer angehen ziel ist es
multi-nationale Konzerne überall in
Europa mit 15 Prozent zu besteuern noch
umgehen Unternehmen wie Apple Google
oder Facebook Milliarden an
Steuerzahlungen weil sie ihre
europäischen Hauptsitze in Irland
angesiedelt haben dort gelten derzeit
deutlich niedrigere Steuersätze
fragen wir Frank beetmann in Frankfurt
an der Börse wie effektiv kann dieser
Schritt der EU sein naja die
Mindeststeuer ist gut sie ist richtig
aber sie kann nur einen Anfang sein gut
ist dass wir hier von 15% effektiven
Steuern reden heißt zahlt ein Konzern
tatsächlich weniger als diese 15 Prozent
egal wo muss er seine Gewinne im
Heimatland nach versteuern es wäre
allerdings naiv zu glauben das wäre es
jetzt eher dürften die großen
beratungskanzleien bereits am neuen
Steuervermeidung Strategien Arbeiten ein
Schwachpunkt ist ganz sicher dass die
mindeststeuerregelung wirklich nur auf
Großkonzerne mit mehr als 750 Millionen
Euro Umsatz im Jahr Anwendung findet
dabei gibt es viele viele Unternehmen
nicht ganz so groß die mindestens ebenso
gut darin sind sich in Sachen Steuern
klein zu rechnen danke schön
wir bleiben in Europa das EU-Parlament
in Straßburg hat erste Konsequenzen im
Korruptions Skandal um vizepräsidentin
gezogen und mit großer Mehrheit für ihre
sofortige Absetzung gestimmt die
griechische Abgeordnete steht unter
Verdacht vom Golfstaat Kata bestochen
worden zu sein und sitzt derzeit in
Untersuchungshaft sie bestreitet die
Vorwürfe
weiter jetzt mit einer Entscheidung der
Bundesregierung wichtig und aktuell bei
den eisigen Temperaturen bislang wurden
ja nur Gas und Strom und Fernwärmekunden
entlastet und jetzt soll es auch Hilfen
beim Heizen mit Öl und mit Pellets geben
bis zu 2000 € pro Haushalt sind da im
Gespräch schauen wir mal wie viele das
betrifft während die Haushalte während
die Hälfte der Haushalte Gas nutzt heizt
ein Viertel mit Öl und dahinter
Fernwärme und Pellets bzw Holz ähnlich
wie Gas sind auch Öl und Pellets zuletzt
immer teurer geworden Andreas
Heizen mit Öl oder mit Holzpellets vor
allem im ländlichen Raum sehr häufig
verbreitet bislang gibt es für diese Art
der Wärmeerzeugung keine Zuschüsse von
Seiten der Bundesregierung das soll sich
jetzt ändern wer eine Pelletheizung hat
wo die Holzpreise gestiegen sind eine
Ölheizung hat wo die Ölpreise gestiegen
sind da verstehe ich sehr gut dass diese
Menschen sagen ja was passiert mit Strom
und gaspreisbremse dann mit mir und
deswegen werden wir das jetzt diese
Woche im Bundestag beschließen der Plan
der Bundesregierung sieht vor sogenannte
nicht leitungsgebundenen Brennstoffe
rückwirkend zu entlasten Zeitraum vom
ersten ersten diesen Jahres bis zum 1.12
hat sich die Heizung in diesen Zeitraum
im Vergleich zum Vorjahr mehr als
verdoppelt dann werden 80% der
zusätzlichen Kosten erstattet pro
Haushalt gibt es maximal 2000 €
insgesamt lässt sich der Bund das 1,8
Milliarden kosten wer was und wie viel
bekommt das sollen die Bundesländer
organisieren
wir werden das dann schon annehmen und
es wird schon was einfallen wie wir
helfen können mit einer Einmalzahlung
wir werden es auch sicher administrieren
können aber es ist halt einfach ein ganz
schlechter Stil im Umgang zwischen Bund
und Ländern für die Linke zu wenig nicht
mehr als der berühmte Tropfen auf dem
heißen Stein wir wissen es von den
anderen Entlastungen dass sie halt
kleine Schritte sind die natürlich
besser sind als nichts aber die nicht
davor schützen dass nenne Bevölkerung
auch in diesem Winter in große
Schwierigkeiten kommen ihre Wohnung
beheizen zu können mit der Preisbremse
für Heizöl und Pellets will die
Ampelkoalition eine viel kritisierte
entlastungslücke schließen bis Ende der
Woche soll aus dem Plan ein Gesetz
werden
ja wir hier können ja heizen Millionen
in der Ukraine wissen nicht mal wie sie
den Winter überstehen sollen weil
Russland eben Wohnhäuser zerstört und
gezielt Strom und Wasserversorgung
angreift deshalb gibt es jetzt eine
Milliarde Euro Winterhilfe für die
Ukraine zugesagt von rund 70 Staaten auf
einer unterstützerkonferenz in Paris
Außenministerin bärbock sagte Geld
allein Schütze nicht vor dem Erfrieren
außerdem notwendig technische Hilfe und
Sachspenden und wie groß die Not
tatsächlich ist das zeigt uns jetzt eine
Brühl
überall in hakiff gibt es Baustellen
hier wird repariert was russische
Raketen in diesem Krieg zerstört haben
sowie in diesem Haus in der Innenstadt
alle arbeiten parallel die Installateure
arbeiten jetzt an der Heizung im
Dachgeschoss
an 40 Wohnblocks wird in haakev
gearbeitet dazu kommen die vielen
tausend Wohnungen in denen Strom und
Wasser nicht regelmäßig funktionieren
wer zu Hause nicht kochen kann der geht
in die Schule 122 bis zu 700 Mittagessen
werden alleine hier ausgegeben bezahlt
von der Stadt
heute gibt es zum Mittagessen Borscht
mit Bohnen Hirsebrei mit büchsenfleisch
und Kakao
ab 4 Uhr versinkt die Stadt in
Dunkelheit in sativ-car brennt nur in
wenigen Wohnungen Licht nata und ihr
Mann wohnen im fünften Stock die Heizung
funktioniert gerade Angst vor dem Winter
haben sie trotzdem
wenn wir genügend Gas haben dann können
wir es ertragen aber wenn wir kein Gas
und keinen Strom haben
Nathan klingt entschlossener als ihr
Mann
ich hasse Putin ich hasse ihn so sehr
dass ich überleben werde trotz alledem
weitermachen irgendwie auch wenn das
immer schwieriger wird
im Terrorprozess um den Anschlag von
Nizza ist jetzt ein Urteil gefallen alle
acht Angeklagten wurden schuldig
gesprochen sie müssen zwischen zwei und
18 Jahre in Haft den Haupttäter hatte
die Polizei damals erschossen am 14 Juli
2016 im französischen Nationalfeiertag
war dieser mit einem Lastwagen in die
Menschenmassen auf der Uferpromenade
gefahren er gab auch Schüsse ab 86
Menschen starben
er hatte am höchsten jüdischen Feiertag
Jom Kippur ein Attentat auf die Synagoge
von Halle verübt jetzt hat er im
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis Magdeburg zwei
Bedienstete als Geiseln genommen sie
wurden nach kurzer Zeit befreit nur der
Attentäter erlitt Verletzungen er hatte
im Oktober 2016 versucht in die Synagoge
von Halle einzudringen als in dies nicht
gelang tötete er zwei Menschen und
verletzte weitere
mindestens 10 Milliarden Euro so viel
hat der cum ex-skandal den deutschen
Staat gekostet jetzt hat das Bonner
Landgericht dann in 72-Jährigen
Steueranwalt zu acht Jahren Haft
verurteilt hanno Berger gilt als einer
der zentralen Köpfe hinter cumex bei
diesen Deals der wurden Aktien so
schnell hin und her geschoben bis der
Fiskus nicht mehr wusste wem sie
eigentlich gehören statt die fällige
Kapitalertragsteuer nur dem
Aktienbesitzer zurückzuzahlen der sie
auch bezahlt hatte erstattete das
Finanzamt sie gleich mehrfach dort
Färber und Anja klingen
hanno Berger Steueranwalt gilt als
Mister cum-ex Berger hat ein
Geschäftsmodell befördert das den Staat
um enorme Steuereinnahmen gebracht hat
in den hier verhandelten Fällen allein
um 276 Millionen Euro das Gericht
begründet 8 Jahre Freiheitsstrafe wegen
Steuerhinterziehung
die hohe kriminelle Energie die
besondere Bedeutung dieser Art von
Wirtschaftskriminalität der extrem hohe
Steuerschaden der dem Fiskus entstanden
ist und dass er Angeklagte auch bis
zuletzt eigentlich die Kamera davon
überzeugen wollte dass er doch recht
getan hat Berger berriet Banken und
Investoren bei cum-ex-geschäften
kassierte dafür Millionen Provisionen
als ehemaliger Beamter der hessischen
Steuerverwaltung kannte sich Berger sehr
gut im Steuerrecht aus 2012 hatte er
sich in die Schweiz abgesetzt wurde
vergangenes Jahr nach Deutschland
ausgeliefert der Bundesgerichtshof hatte
die kommen ex-geschäfte als Straftat
gewertet Berger gilt als Schlüsselfigur
wenn Sie den Strafrahmen sehen wie auch
der hervorsitzende vorgerechnet hat kann
man durchaus auch gütige Seiten sehen da
wurden durchaus auch Dinge zugunsten von
Herrn Berger berücksichtigt das Gericht
entscheidet auch 13 Millionen Euro vom
Bergers Vermögen einzuziehen und vor dem
Landgericht Wiesbaden läuft auch noch
ein cum-ex-verfahren Berger drohen
weitere Strafen
bei einer bundesweiten Razzia gegen
klimaaktivisten der sogenannten letzten
Generation hat die Polizei 11 Wohnungen
durchsucht hintergrund war die Besetzung
einer Station der PCK Raffinerie in
Brandenburg die Staatsanwaltschaft
Neuruppin ermittelt wegen Störung
öffentlicher Betriebe und des Verdachts
der Bildung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung
etwas in eigener Sache das Morgenmagazin
von ZDF und ARD ist heute ausgefallen
Gewerkschaften haben ohne vorherige
Ankündigung den Sendebetrieb im ZDF
bestreikt betroffen waren auch heute
Express-Sendungen und volle Kanne die
Gewerkschaften bemängeln dass sich bei
den laufenden Tarifverhandlungen nicht
wirklich etwas bewege die nächste
Verhandlungsrunde ist am 21 Dezember
jetzt zu nicht weniger als einem
Menschheitstraum sauber und sicher
Energie gewinnen durch Kernfusion seit
den 1960er Jahren wird er geträumt
bislang aber scheiterten alle Ansätze an
den schwierigen Voraussetzungen damit
Atomkerne fusionieren können braucht es
extrem hohe Temperaturen das bislang
unerreichte Ziel am Ende soll mehr
Energie gewonnen als verbraucht werden
dazu jetzt Benjamin Daniel mit einer
erfolgsversprechenden Meldung aus den
USA
was da oben in den Sternen passiert ist
nun erstmals auch hier unten auf der
Erde gelungen
wasserstoffatomkerne verschmelzen und
werden zu Helium dabei wird mehr Energie
freigesetzt als verbraucht Forschern ist
das in einem Labor in Kalifornien mit
Hilfe von Laser Bestrahlung gelungen die
us-energieministerin spricht von einem
historischen Durchbruch
dieser Meilenstein bringt uns einen
riesigen Schritt näher an die
Möglichkeit heran unsere Gesellschaft
mit komplett CO2 freier fusions Energie
zu versorgen
was auf den ersten Blick
vielversprechend klingt hat allerdings
noch einen Haken noch muss zu viel
Energie investiert werden denn riesige
Mengen Laserstrahlen müssen dafür in
einen Zylinder geschossen werden dort
verdichtet sich dann die Energie zu
gezielter Röntgenstrahlung sie bringt am
Ende eine Kapsel mit Wasserstoff zur
Zündung bei der mehr Energie frei wird
als der Strahl mitbringt
nur in diesem letzten Schritt etwa ein
Drittel um den Prozess zu starten ist
also ein riesiger Energieaufwand nötig
dieses Problem zu lösen wird wohl noch
Jahrzehnte dauern
es hat einen Schritt auf einem langen
Weg man kann auch nicht direkt diese
Methode benutzen für einen Kraftwerk und
man muss das ganze dann 20 Mal pro
Sekunde machen und das ist schon noch
ein langer Weg aber ist halt ein Schritt
auf diesem Weg zu einem Fusionskraftwerk
eine kurzfristige Lösung unserer
Energieprobleme verspricht das gelungene
Experiment also nicht auf die lange
Strecke aber könnte der Griff nach den
Sternen gelingen und für die Menschheit
vieles verändern
während bei der WM die Halbfinals
anstehen arbeitet der DFB die Pleite auf
und dazu gab es Christine ziemlich lange
Pressekonferenz heute sehr lange aber
man setzt auf große Erfahrung zehn
Monate ist Präsident Bernd Neuendorf im
Amt und mit Blick auf die EM 24 in
Deutschland soll nun unter anderem eine
Arbeitsgruppe gespickt mit Prominenz und
reichlich Fachwissen helfen den
dfb-sportlich in die Erfolgsspur
zurückzuführen der Präsident hat einen
Rettungsplan die ehemaligen dfb-stars
Oliver Kahn Karl-Heinz Rummenigge
Matthias Sammer und Rudi Völler dazu
rb-chef Oliver mintzlaff sollen die
Nationalmannschaft wieder auf Kurs
bringen wir müssen jetzt die Kräfte
bündeln Richtung euro24 weil das muss
denke ich und das wollen wir alle zu
einem Erfolg werden Hauptaufgabe die
Suche eines Nachfolgers für Oliver
Bierhoff zum missglückten
Krisenkommunikation rund um die One Love
Kapitänsbinde äußerte sich Neuendorf
selbstkritisch das Thema ist dann
Richtung immer näher Richtung Turnier
gel bis ins Turnier hineingetragen
worden aus heutiger Sicht und mit ein
paar Tagen Abstand muss ich sagen hätte
ich hier heute anders gehandelt klar ist
für den Neuaufbau einer titelfähigen
Mannschaft bis zur EM im eigenen Land
bleiben nur noch 18 Monate Zeit
heute Abend das erste Halbfinale bei der
WM in Katar Argentinien gegen Kroatien
das bedeutet auch Messi gegen Modric
beide stehen in der jeweiligen Stadt ist
für uns wieder dabei ist wenn Voss noch
einmal die beiden als das Gegeneinander
das schwingt ja auch ein bisschen Wehmut
mit
ja es wird wohl der letzte Tanz auf der
ganz großen Bühne für die beiden
Weltfußballer Luka Modric und Lionel
Messi 2006 trafen die beiden zum ersten
Mal bei einer WM aufeinander damals
schoss Messi sein erstes Tor aber Modric
und Kroatien gewannen und heute schließt
sich sozusagen der Kreis denn es wird
für beide wohl das letzte WM-Turnier
sein Lionel Messi ist den Top-Form vier
Tore und zwei Torvorlagen aber auch
nicht zu unterschätzen sind die
argentinischen Fans im Viertelfinale
gegen die Niederlande waren 40.000
argentinia im Stadion und heute werden
es kaum weniger sein Messi gegen Modric
nur einer Schaft ins Finale das ist
sicher danke schön Sven nach Katar und
morgen dann live im ZDF Frankreich
Marokko das wird richtig spannend danke
schön Christin vielleicht musstest du
heute morgen auch Auto schreiben ich
musste das jedenfalls es ist sehr kalt
in Deutschland geworden traumhafte
Bilder lieferte bei der Kälte zumindest
der Sonnenaufgang am Fichtelberg in
Sachsen
eisiges Skulpturen geformt von Schnee
Wind und Frost Fotografen fanden auf
1200 Meter über Normalnull viele Motive
weiter unten Rodelspaß und da machen
natürlich alle sehr gerne mit
zum Schluss noch eine kleine Korrektur
der Anschlag auf die Synagoge in Halle
fand natürlich 2019 statt und nicht wie
ich gesagt habe 2016 sorry dafür
Glatteis Regen heute Nacht mehr hat
gleich Katja horneffer Christian Sievers
meldet sich später um 21:45 Uhr mit dem
heute journal danke schön fürs Interesse
schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine gefährliche
Nacht denn es setzt Glatteisregen ein in
der zweiten Nachthälfte zunächst am
Bodensee in Oberschwaben und im Allgäu
und bis zum Morgen erreicht dieser
Glatteisregen auch München dann setzt
auch hier von der Schweiz neuer Glatteis
Regen ein machen Sie sich also auf
Glätte gefasst im Süden von
Baden-Württemberg und von Bayern und das
auch noch morgen über Tag vermeidbare
Wege verschieben sie morgen also besser
denn es bleibt bei Glatteis Regen auch
über Tag im Norden da gibt's kräftige
Schneefälle das können zwei bis zehn
Zentimeter Schnee werden von all dem
bekommen sie in Norddeutschland gar
nichts ab in Norddeutschland kann es
vielleicht in der Nacht mal für einen
Schneeschauer hier Nordfriesland reichen
und es gibt strengen Frost hier im Osten
da sinken die Werte bis minus 12 Grad
nicht ganz so eisig wird es im Westen
und morgen liegen die Temperaturen meist
im leichten Dauerfrost selten klettern
die Temperaturen über 0 Rat nur im
Allgäu da werden es bis zu 6 Grad und
das bedeutet dass am Nachmittag Regen in
die Reste von Glatteis und Schnee
hineinfallen werden der Donnerstag wird
eher ruhig der Freitag aber bringt dann
schon wieder Glätte in Süddeutschland
guten Abend